what is it a lien Queens there's a nice
Empress of Mars series 10 episode 9 the
Ice Warriors are back and yeah so I was
nervous going to this one I swore it I
thought it was cool when they came back
previously and Matt Smith had his
episode with them it wasn't a phenomenal
episode but I was I thought it was cool
to see them revisit the Ice Warriors as
a race and in a way almost kind of give
them the the Dalek treatment and by that
I mean the episode it titled Dalek from
series 1 sort of like look we used to
deal with massive let's just deal with
one and show you why one of these is bad
news I think for what it was trying that
episode was fine and did it pretty well
but I don't I didn't feel a need or a
particular draw to see the Ice Warriors
again so I was nervous going in and
getting it you know it's fine I don't
think there's a ton that's really
horrible about this episode there's just
very few solid strengths is the thing a
lot of it's just a wash and this version
of the Ice Warriors between the Queen
and the resolution it feels like they
took the racnoss Queen and mixture up
with the Silurians and that feels very
much like what we got here there are I
mean that part of me loves the bonkers
nature of the press of the premise
beyond the Victorian era British very
step up a lip you know British there on
Mars that's nuts
and I like another idea it just didn't
yield a heck of a lot in terms of you
know what you got from the characters
that I think if you've seen many Doctor
Who episodes the pattern was really easy
to suss out and you know and this is
sort of a it just feels very boilerplate
it feels like a quote-unquote standard
Doctor Who is like here's the group of
humans and
them's kind of okay some of them are
jerks someone's going to be an idiot and
cause a problem someone's going to be
trigger-happy and cause more problems
the aliens will be angry that dead
accident that now I mean the this sort
of thing has gone on since the classic
era the difference is back in the
classic era a usually result in the
aliens getting wiped out modern era
usually results in more of a truce
situation so there's that difference but
it just it just feels completely
bog-standard um and there are little
things that I like though and it pretty
much is little things it is little
touches um so like when the Empress was
starting to revive everybody in the and
they started to light up in the walls
you saw the silhouettes of the eyesores
I liked that individual first of all in
terms of showing you the scope ooh what
how many of those things are work and I
liked it it's kind of a visual nod to
tombs of the Cybermen which is a classic
Doctor Who episode you know a story one
of the best second doctor stories that
you will ever see definitely think that
out if you've never seen it but it felt
like a fun nod to that the Empress I
think she got a decent redesign because
the Ice Warriors were redesigned very
minimally they were kept pretty true to
that original design which is very dated
and very hokey they were able to
streamline her enough and honestly kind
of the the Predators henges they gave
her which were kind of shiny sparkly
that was a nice touch so I think she had
a better design so it was probably good
that most of the visual emphasis was on
her and out the soldiers who I you know
they they look like Lego men they just
do I didn't kind of like the whole art
with the commander the idea that you
know that he was a coward and he you
know was not successfully punished for
that and sort of him Stan Hammond and
then who volunteering to serve the Queen
that that was interesting enough that
it's like I I don't want to see more of
the ice [ __ ] but I don't want to know
what happened to him because that's
interesting and that's different and
that's a fun twist on term in terms of
the conclusion but I can't I don't I
don't know what there is lips to get out
of the Ice Warriors I really did love
the moment with Missy and the doctor and
the TARDIS at the end though
because there was something about it
there was because I mean it was very
obvious she wanted out of the vault and
you knew Naruto was going to get her out
and you know it was like oh god was
going to go wrong but the idea that she
just went to pick him up and he said you
know I have to put you back in the ball
and say I know but that moment that they
shared that was fascinating to me I
don't I don't know for certain where
things are going with Missy with the
master but I'm I'm in I'm really in on
that because the dynamic that's going on
is so intriguing to me and it's so
different yet feels correct it doesn't
feel like a betrayal of anybody's
character so watching her I don't know
if it's struggling against her instincts
I don't know I don't know but just
trying to be quote unquote good it's
it's really fascinating it's you know I
say how much I love it it's 20 seconds
of the episode so and and completely
disconnected from the story that's told
I'm feeling this is the episode that
some people are going to legitimately
hate I think it I think it depends on
how much just kind of hoping this gets
to you because you know between how sort
of kitd and the queen is at how those
bloody aliens the you know the kingdom
the bad British commander was and you
know the look of the of the ice wars
between all that I suspect this is an
episode of some people are going to
legitimately hate because none of those
are particularly good elements in my
mind none of them were bad enough to be
worth hating it's just a very
forgettable episode it's the sort of
thing I'm never going to feel the need
to ever watch again but it's not
something I can work of any kind of
anger about either it's just kind of and
then I'm glad I recorded this really
soon after I watch it because hey I
think my brain is just going to start
scrubbing it pretty quick out of the one
other thing I want to mention is that
that weapon that the Ice Warriors had
the first time they shot somebody with
it I thought that was really cool and
though I don't know I didn't rewind it
and reach
but I don't know if it was done
different or if there was a different
sound effect or even just done with a
different sense of impact but it's that
first time they use it
it felt more impactful it felt like the
the condensing was was more violent you
know the sort of commute thing and I was
like oh whoa but then he showed it more
after that and it lost that sense of
violent contraction and then they and
when the bodies fall they kind of bounce
and it became goofy so I don't think was
a bad idea because the first time I saw
it it looked like it hurt so they sold
it with that first one but then every
time was used after that it just got
sillier and sillier and sillier so again
that's one more thing I don't hate it
there's almost nothing I like about this
episode but I don't hate it it doesn't
leave enough of an impact for me to work
up a good you know healthy amount of
bile against that it's just it was I I
will say so far for me easily the worst
episode of this series so far so but
yeah I mean given that I have really
been enjoying this series that that
still doesn't mean you know I don't hate
it it's just way down there now if you
haven't been enjoying this series
already I filmed mystical it was
probably really painful for you but what
were your thoughts on Empress of Mars
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen with council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher
I am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast also available on iTunes
and stitcher so you gave a listen to
those give me your thoughts and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]